We know this is the answer. This rational expression is the odd one out, since
it equals positive 1. This expression over here is really equal to negative 1,
since x minus 7 divided by the quantity x minus 7 simplifies to 1. We get a
negative 1 since we have a negative sign sitting out here. This is really
negative 1 times 1. For this first rational expression, we can switch the order
of the denominator. I can have the negative x come first, and then followed by
the positive 7. We can see that this expression is the same as this last
expression down here. But this doesn't quite look like negative 1. But these two
rational expressions don't look like negative 1, but in fact, they are. We know
these expressions in the numerator and denominator are opposite polynomials. The
x terms are opposite in sign, as are the constant terms. We can factor a
negative 1 from our denominator to get negative 1 times x minus 7. Then we can
simplify our common factors in the numerator and denominator, leaving us with
negative 1. Nice thinking if you found that one.